[Music]
welcome to another stories from the
stores joined today by curator Alex Rose
and she's telling us about Britain's
obsession with the weather or at least
clouds what's going on Alex people have
long been fascinated with the clouds but
clouds have long been a problem for
scientists because they're so transient
by the time you've described one it's
kind of changed into something else and
so they always felt like they were
beyond a scientific description I mean
is there really any scientific
description needed because you've got
three big small dinosaur yeah I mean
that pretty much sums it up but there
was a man working in the early 19th
century who wanted to give more
scientific names to the clouds and so he
came up with a classification system
that divided them into about three main
families and he gave them Latin names
though so he called them cirrus which is
the Latin word for curl of hair Stratos
which means layer and cumulus which
means heat or pile in order to capture
the sky that he was looking at and help
his own understanding he made lots and
lots of sketches and watercolors of the
sky and the cloud structures and that
was what helped him to see patterns in
what he was looking at and to come up
with this classification system so are
these sort of specific forms of clouds
here yeah that's right so here we've got
mostly gotten a cumulus cloud so the
heat will pile and there's also some
saracen Stratus up in the sky this one
is a kind of hybrid version so how it
also wanted to describe how clouds
changed how they join together and split
apart so this is a team you know Stratus
cloud so you say it's science but this
looks more like heart why then he draw
these so it was to help him sort of
understand his own observations because
the clouds kept changing so he needed to
find a way of recording them and
comparing things he'd seen from day to
day on these he worked with another
artist who filled in the landscapes but
art works like these are essential for
him communicating his ideas to the wider
scientific
okay so he's classified the clouds from
these drawings but why do we care it's a
good question
so when Howard was working meteorology
was still a really young science and it
was still very much about gathering as
much data as you possibly could in as
many observations as you could and kind
of hoping that patterns would would
appear from those observations but
Howard's scheme allowed us to to start
to view the clouds in a scientific way
[Music]